this is a production of Cornell
University
I got a picture of you a few years ago
with you darling who made that guest
appearance I remember when we you know
this was right when the pandemic started
I think we were a month maybe a month
and a half into it we were all locked up
nobody nobody knew what was going to
happen and what'd you say she's four now
yeah she's four and a half so so great
yeah good for you so cute as ever all
right so listen
um I'm taking the place of Carl's rant
today a little bit and I'm going to uh
ran a little bit about what what is
about to come upon us next week as we
enter the month of May
um this whole concept of nomome has
really got some traction and I have to
say you know thinking about lawns in a
different way inherently is not a bad
thing I think we've been stuck in a
pretty pretty consistent Paradigm uh
around Lawns and social construct around
Lawns if you want to think about it
sociologically for a really long time we
we have the impression that Lawns and
things have to look a certain way
um and it is mostly a subjective thing
in in many times so we have been many
years and Carl has really taken the
leadership on this recently in
um getting us to look at the ecosystem
Services of Lawns and one of the aspects
of those Services is how it can help
pollinators and particularly local
pollinators so just a few years ago a
paper was published uh by a few
entomologists who had done some work in
the city of Appleton Wisconsin and
unfortunately that paper has had to be
retracted because of uh potential
inconsistencies and data handling and
Reporting the the back story here is
they somewhat identify they identified
species of insects that simply do not
exist in that part of Wisconsin so so
this sort of undermined this thing more
very recently uh from an academic
perspective again not that it is a bad
thing to want to have Lawns looked at
differently and potentially looking at
them as flowering opportunities and
foraging opportunities for for local
pollinators so so this is obviously
something of concern because you know we
spent a lot of time talking about this
you know leaving the debris in your
garden right Jen Lerner one of our great
extension faculty in the field has
really sort of you know sort of been
working more with this and and Joella
lamp has been working more with this
this isn't something we are kicking to
the curb because a paper got retracted
nor is it something we generally dis you
know don't want to do in a lawn but like
everything else you know we sort of are
stuck by the fact that we gotta maybe we
should think what science says about
this so there is a really a lot of good
work coming out of Minnesota Minnesota
has actually rebates they'll provide you
if you start planting these seeds in the
lawn so so there's lots of ways to think
about a traditional law and a bee lawn
an urban Meadow all these sorts of
things you know are different ways of
viewing your lawn but I can tell you it
gets in it gets more and more
challenging to manage the kind of lawn
you want might want to have the more
diversity uh you put in it because even
in that diversity there's going to be
plants maybe that you don't want now I
wanted to rant a little bit about not
mowing for a month because this is the
thing that sort of you know uh gets in
there under all of us turf grass
extension people's skin here
um we have embraced mowing less at
Cornell University our signature
landscape live slope next to the tower
is not mode but once a year and it has
met with widespread acceptance since we
started it in ready for it 2009. we've
been at this a really long time and it's
gone through a couple of directors of
grounds management now led by Dan
scheiden Dan has totally embraced it and
of course giving it this great name Tall
Grass less gas now there also are places
in the home landscape and in the long
where maybe this kind of lawn no more
lawn this is what it looks like when you
plant one of those Low Mo Lawns you
basically get a collection of fine
fescues that flop over when they get
really tall many times we'll produce
seed heads and that and that gives it a
more of a metal look so let's look at
Molly I thought I would take us back to
Turfgrass 101 and let's look at more
what should every turf grass manager
know about mowing natural turf grass is
regular mode it's the nature of the
definition of turf mowing wounds and
influences the way plant grows it
selects for the type of plants that are
there it dictates the mowing regime how
much you have to mow and how much you
mow depends on the kind equipment now
that is a own area as we try to mow
higher okay sharpen the blade 10 hours
of use the blade should get a look at if
you've hit anything you should grind out
those chips so for sure if you're into
professional grounds management business
you've got a mower blade sharpening
program
mowing higher
reduces the density of plants right
mowing higher reduces the density of
plants mowing lower increases the
density of plants so you get more plants
per unit area when you mow lower when
you mow higher you get fewer bigger
plants when you mow lower you get more
smaller plants now when you mow too
close and you thin the canopy and expose
the ground you get sunlight penetrating
the soil this is a lot of what happens
when you go from nomomay to the first of
June and you want to mow those plants
are going to get thinner and bigger and
you're going to come in and try to bring
them down to their normal height and
that's going to weaken those plants and
create opportunities for weeds mowing
higher lets the roots grow deeper
nothing new here mowing higher off also
will allow plants with creeping growth
habits to adapt to the mowing regime you
know ground ivy is one of them winter
annual weeds if you keep a higher cut
Turf you might have more winter annual
Weeds now there's a value to these
flowering winter annual weeds sometimes
because if you want to have a flowering
lawn these are some of the early flowers
in lawns that can support visiting
pollinators that visit your area early
now once you start to do this you can't
once you start having a flowering lawn
it can't be spraying stuff on your grass
either because everything you hit on
those flowers potentially is going to
get absorbed and then bioaccumulated
back at wherever these pollinators are
hanging out
my colleague at University of Guelph and
Sarah Stricker his colleague in
Communications there uh Eric Lyons and
Sarah Stricker came out pretty strong
that says this might be this is a bad
idea for Canadian Lawns they're talking
about how it could lead to not only
weakened grass uh dandelions aren't
going to save the bees you could get
infestations with difficult to control
weeds uh like uh thistles uh dead
Nettles things that survive under less
mowing yesterday we heard from Jen
Lerner in our conference call that
herpetologists thinks snakes will start
to inhabit these areas and so that's the
that's the end of it for me I'm I'm not
going anywhere near snakes now grass
type also affects how much you have to
mow so if depending on the grass type
you have like if you have a lynx fine
Fescue Mo that Jim Wilmont showed many
years ago produces about a third of the
clippings that uh rye grass fine Fescue
area does or a Turf type tall fescue
area does if you're really serious about
mowing less you should get grasses that
grow less and once they start to grow
less you know that gives other plants
potentially opportunities to fill in now
the classic one-third rule the don't
remove more than 30 percent of the leaf
tissue every time you mow this was the
way we've always talked about it if you
keep your lawn at one inch you gotta mow
it when it gets to an inch and a half
and that's once every one to three days
on the average over the course of a
season if you mow it two inches you got
to let it grow to three inches to keep a
slow growth rate and that's every five
to seven days you go to three inches you
let it can go to four and a half inches
now you got 10 to 14 days between mowing
my former grad student and uh president
and founder of green keeper during his
time at the University of Nebraska has
done a lot of work looking at the impact
of the one-third rule on growth rate so
he took a tall fescue area out in
Nebraska and then decided uh to mow it
either at two inches or three inches
either took off 25 percent of the leaf
tissue 33 percent of the leaf tissue or
50 percent of the leaf tissue or just
weekly mowing okay and then he counted
the amount of mowings that occurred he
counted the amount of clippings that
were produced and some very clear
findings emerged okay 50 percent removal
grew the most
so if you uh let your three inch Turf go
to six inches and cut it down back to
three inches It produced more clippings
than mowing it at four and a half inches
to keep your area at two inches and you
let it go to four inches right
it's also going to grow more and produce
more clippings so this is what it looks
like in a graphical representation this
is the one season of growing he's
looking at the cumulative clipping yield
two inches fifty percent removal and
three inches fifty percent removal the
most clipping production which means
you're harvesting nutrients out of the
ground you're using carbohydrates in
those plants more frequently to produce
those clippings and one could say that
leads to an overall weakening of the
turf so mowing higher and following the
30 percent rule or the 25 percent rule
will certainly produce less clippings
you will mow less if you follow the
one-third rule you will mow
less overall now you mow less because of
50 removal you have fewer mowings when
you go to 50 removal but you produce
more clippings right the 33 removal is a
more uniform form of growth to 50
removal becomes weedy and weak
so here's our final word before we get
into our conversation with Matt about
weeds today consistently mowing cool
season grasses at three inches or higher
will reduce the total number of mowings
by maintaining the slowest growth rate
you produce less clippings Shades the
surface to prevent annual weeds from
germinating allows for certain
incidental flowering plants we sometimes
call those things weeds to coexist and
this may serve as a important food
source for local pollinators but I think
my colleague Eric Lyons is comment at
Guelph is well taken there's a lot
better ways for these pollinators to get
serviced in these environments than uh
just having your lawn flowering now
let's do a quick look at the weather and
then we'll get on to our weed discussion
it after a very warm week last week it
got pretty cool we were two to four
degrees below normal only a few places
were close to normal we are well ahead
on accumulated degree days from March
15th in some places two to three weeks
ahead of normal uh which is the 30-year
average so you you know we had a really
warm spell everybody knows it was a
pretty mild winter we had a hot period
at the end of February this doesn't even
account for that warm period at the end
of February this is just from the middle
of March it's saying we've really pushed
ahead
now total precipitation we everybody got
about an inch uh some places like in
stores and along Southeastern New
England they got about three to four
inches but everybody got about a half to
an inch and this has really uh solved a
lot of the drought problems that we were
starting to see particularly towards the
south end of the region
and the Outlook is looking is basically
saying we're going to be in a pause for
at least the next eight to ten days for
sure it looks like the probability of
being cooler than normal is above 50
percent and the probability for it being
wetter than normal is above 50 percent
so we're going to get a fair amount of
rainfall moving in over the next five to
seven days so it will be cloudy and
rainy for a while so it's also going to
be tough to get out and do the mowing as
we head into nomome
the weird thing about this season is
soils we're warm there for a minute and
now they've significantly cooled off now
they've significantly cooled off hold on
the guy's mowing outside
okay there we go thanks Dan we gotta
call this guy and get him out of here
mowing but they're working diligently
before the rainfall comes now one of the
things that has happened is soils are
cooled off and I think this has really
slowed the germination of crabgrass
forsythias are come and gone and
normally we associate that with
crabgrass germination and emergence
right so so obviously this creates a
pretty interesting disconnect between
what we normally think models are
helping us to predict what we think a
phenological indicators will help us to
predict and looking at the soils which
have been fluctuating and not staying
consistently warm so these indicators
might not be the best tool this year
Matt so I thought I would talk a little
bit about non-chemical stuff and uh
crabgrass control and it goes all the
way back to Peter noden's day where he
looked at you know uh inch and a half uh
two inches uh three and a half inches
and he found that overall if you wanted
to reduce crabgrass infestation mowing
higher is definitely the way to go
especially without any herbicide right
when you don't have an herbicide you
can't use an herbicide then having uh
that grass mode higher is definitely
going to keep that crabgrass at Bay and
here is that particular graph now mowing
higher if you've already put your
pre-emergent herbicide down now we're
going to see what happens to the length
of crabgrass germination and if your
pre-emergence is going to hold on
because we know that crabgrass follows
that sort of classic sigmoidal curve
where you get a little bit in the early
phase and then a consistent amount for a
period of time and so when you look at
this work by Jeffries and Gannon in 2016
they looked at Dimension uh
pandemethylene and pro-diomine
diethiopyroprene
um and pro-diamene or barricade at two
different mowing Heights now for
Dimension and pendimethylin mowing at an
inch and three quarters definitely
reduced uh overall crabgrass control and
neither of those products uh dithiopia
and pendameethylene independent of
mowing height were as good as barricade
so if you've got to mow lower and you've
got thinner turf or your turf's not
going to be competitive based on this
work and tall fescue it looks like uh
barricade is your choice now Matt you
told me you're going to start looking at
rolling in crabgrass so I just thought
I'd remind everybody that we began to
observe this rolling in crabgrass
control thing at the Vineyard Golf Club
a number of years ago where your
Technique Edition Dan tuck used to work
on a regular basis and Doc Watson
presented some work back in 1950 in the
USGA green section record it's the only
place we could find anything that showed
compaction seemed to decrease the
percentages of crabgrass we've played
around with this this is a year after we
stopped driving over an area you can
still see the crabgrass controlled a
year after we stopped driving over it
with the tires and the rollers Chris
Citgo when he was on the group when he
was out the Vineyard Golf Club actually
went out and rolled five days a week and
was able to control crabgrass in a way
that almost makes it look like you
sprayed it there Matt so let's start
there
crabgrass control uh the disconnect
between the phenological indicators the
soil temperature
and where you think we're at have you
seen any crabgrass and what's your
thoughts about managing it with the way
it's been this spring yeah a great
question so we've we've got crabgrass up
here in New Jersey
um I think it was interesting though I
think we've got an initial flush of
emergence in some areas and then some
areas that are still in a holding pad
where we haven't gotten you know the
temperatures maybe those are higher
higher grass areas denser Turf areas
where the soil temperature hasn't quite
made it to that threshold for
germination so we do have you know kind
of this pause that we're in right now I
guess
um but you know so yeah we've got our
our crabgrass pre-emergence trials are
out and luckily they are because the
crab grasses are already up in our in
our areas
um
so it could be an interesting year I
think now is a good time to get those
those pre-emergence herbicides out if
you haven't already and especially maybe
a year for you know using that reach
back or whatever we want to call it that
the thiopia has the dimension has right
that it can control
newly emerged crabgrass plants
um and then maybe alleviate some of
those worries about you know um
trying to time it perfectly so you don't
have to make a second application right
worried about degradation and that sort
of thing so
scouting is always a good idea looking
in bare soil area south facing slopes
that sort of thing
to make sure you know if you're not
using Dimension that you don't have any
crabgrass emerged it just I think it
just depends where you are and how hot
you got when we had that three-day
stretch a few weeks ago which for us was
85 Degrees 88 degrees so we you know I
even saw Goose grass up
um in a couple places at a an event I
was at earlier this week a sports field
manager's event so it was a little scary
a few weeks ago from from my perspective
of weed management okay so you so you're
saying they've popped but they're just
sitting there
um yeah I think they are right now and
you know it's
the so that's where it's interesting you
know we talk about some of this stuff
like rolling and I think the rolling the
compaction probably impacts germination
but I think also the rolling is going to
kill off some of these small seedlings
where especially right now at a period
where they're not happy
um you know they're C4 plants so they're
they're struggling right now and that's
what we're Dan and I are kind of
wondering is you know I think the the
rolling especially early in the season
might be critical
um but again we're we're excited to look
at that as a again alternative practice
to you know herbicides great so how are
you going to do it what's your I was
curious you're going to set it up what's
your plan for setting up that experiment
we've got right now we've got two
rollers uh we've got a Toba toe behind
you know a tractor or not even a tractor
you could tow behind a car a lawnmower
it's a water filled roller
um that you know anybody could buy and
then we're also going to use
um
one of these heavy equipment type
rollers that actually we use it to roll
our putting greens but okay so yeah if
he's letting you use his pavement roller
yeah the pavement roller you know what
I'm talking about I know exactly what
you're talking about yeah okay yeah all
right so we were also looking at maybe
doing something with a little friction
on it um like the Rutgers wearing
machine but we I think we're just going
to start with something simple and look
at the rolling so right so so this is
very exciting now the crabgrass
conversation I think is very interesting
just to wrap it up you know Dimension
gives you that reach back activity to
get those younger plants so growth stage
matters right you know where it's at
when it's germinating growth stage
matters and it and it starts to matter
again if you miss pre and you got to
start using Quinn clorak and and
phenoxoprop you know later on when we're
not doing the show and you find out how
bad your crabgrass control is you got to
go back out there with some post
products so you do have to pay attention
to your growth stage but it looked
really clear Matt that no matter what a
barricade provides that consistent um if
you know if if you're going out early
you got to push yourself early
um and even if you know you might have a
weak Turf like that study showed we even
with the low-cut Turf
um if you're really relying on your
herbicide to carry all that weight uh
barricade seems like the better option
yeah and we saw that in some work we did
that's um a few years ago now I guess
where we looked at uh early applications
I'm talking like mid-February and um in
one of our locations the barricade did
work better when we made a single
application really early again we were
trying to simulate you know a lawn care
operator who has to get all you know all
gets all the properties right before
crabgrass germinates and you might have
to start in mid-February or maybe really
early March
um and in that situation
um
we did see the diaper and the
pandemethylene again with one
application
High crabgrass pressure in our sandier
soil site the the barricade was better
um so there's there's something to that
I I think your point about dense Turf is
also really important and we've seen
that in some of our other work where you
know single applications of say
Dimension provide maybe 90 control where
we've got thin Turf but then when we
have con had in the same test put it
with a good uh put the fertilizer
program with the dimension all of a
sudden you know everything's 100 control
so that Turf density coupled with you
know say any way you can get density I
think higher mowing Heights the easiest
way to do it but whatever you need to do
um you know you can get by with less
herbicide I think we need more research
to show to investigate that can we get
by with less herbicide where we have
denser Turf right
um like that work that Travis did and
the work that Pete darnon did they were
using full rates and so
um
that stuff's really valuable in it and
it and it shows
um you know that we we need to increase
mowing Heights or you know yeah
cultivate dense
you know if you're going to mow it low
like a you know a golf course you better
be prepared to to provide some more
nutrients as well but listen I don't
even care about crabgrass because I'm
scared you know what of goose grass now
this is a plant that you're saying it's
already germinated okay it has this flat
growing toupee growing habit that it can
survive under really close molding I've
seen it on putting greens now guys you
know can go out and spray it you know
you get the the whitening products that
you know again you have a variety of
products that will work on it
post-emergent
um
pre-emergent is a different deal and so
I want to talk to you about a couple of
things that have come up recently Matt
that's got me concerned and your name is
on them which uh is on at least one of
them so so here we have uh uh Goose
grass resistant to uh dithiopia and we
have resistance to ronstar back from
2017 and you brought this up a number of
years ago I when we started doing the
show you're like you know Frank we have
a crabgrass based pre-program up here in
the Northeast and it's giving Goose
grass an opportunity to expand now
you're telling me I got resistance on
top of this sort of nature of our
constant use and then McElroy and his
group comes out and says uh oh these
things have mutated and you've got all
kinds of different types now that are in
Turf and this Matt you know Scott's been
playing around with resistance so I'm
sure that's how he sort of stumbled into
this a little bit
um How concerned are you about Goose
grass uh I know you were a few years ago
yeah are we are you growing increasingly
concerned based on what you've seen the
last few years
um I I think you know I think I don't
want to say more concerned I think it's
still a big problem I think the I think
in the Northeast I've worked with some
superintendents and turf managers that
have uh adapted and managed to get it
under control I think the key is we need
to you know use different pre-emergents
and and adapt and I think there's a lot
more we need to learn about this weed
um I think it's something that we're
going to have to learn to live with and
the interesting thing about Goose grass
as you just showed is that it has this
propensity to adapt to whatever
situation I think it'll adapt to an
herbicide situation right you did the
same thing 20 years in a row and it says
well I got a way around this and then
management wise it also has clearly
adapted I think it has that ability more
than crabgrass so it's similar to
crabgrass but we have to keep in mind
it's going to adapt um it's clearly you
know it can tolerate low mowing which
crabgrass typically I've never seen
crabgrass really make it through a
summer in a putting green well that's
not too rarely do I see it right so the
goose grass has this ability
again to adapt so we just need to keep
that in mind and I think we need to you
know keep in mind that it's we need an
integrated sort of management approach
we need to think about okay well I
switched my herbicide that's good for
now but you know a lot of
superintendents and turf managers uh
Sports field managers in this region
have switched to oxidized on well you so
you saw what's happened in the Southeast
they saw this they went through this
story 20 years ago so they got
resistance to barricade and now they got
resistance to Ron star so I think we can
preserve the herbicides we have by
looking at other things like mowing
height
post-emergence programs how do we create
Turf density so that those sorts of
things are are really important and this
weed again is gonna I think it's here
for a while it's Gonna Keep moving North
probably okay well
um I got a question from Ben Palmer that
I thought is good before I go to some of
the other things I want to do Matt Benz
asked about winter annual weed control
when you can't spray in the fall because
the fields are under use or you're using
uh your seating and things like that or
by the time you can spray it's it might
be too late so what do you recommend if
for winter annual weed control when
you're in a sports field situation and
you can't spray in a fall
well and you can't spray I mean It's
Tricky you could you can spray in the
spring I don't know if that's an option
Ben but
um
you know the winter annuals I find I
guess if there's anything it might be a
seating program they're not very
competitive they I mean I realize you've
got a lot of wear so it's It's Tricky
they they like the Open Spaces I don't
see them usually establishing very well
where you've got you know a really dense
stand to Turf of course there's constant
wear from the games so you know I'd
really there's not a whole lot that I
can think of that you can do
um if you can't spray you know for it
basically in the fall so so you'd have
to you know my first guess would be
um get as much either get as much seed
on as you can uh or or when they're done
yeah well more more issues in Municipal
Lawns uh than Sports Fields so it looks
like traffic isn't the issue right based
on what Ben's saying so it's not that
he's getting thinning Turf it's that he
can't get out there in the municipal
lawns in the fall to spray right so
those plants are getting robust quickly
so if you don't have to seed can we put
a pre on late
yeah the tricky thing would be you know
a lot of these things are going to start
coming up early September mid-september
through you know sometimes later so
you'd have to get the pre-emerge out you
know early
um you could use a pre-emerge like a
socks have been or something like that
if you have to just get it out
uh early I don't know when you could get
out there to spray you know uh when when
that's available but they they do
germinate you know we get that first
cool batch of cool weather in the fall
and if the soils are wet a lot of them
will germinate so
we got we got another question from a
guy uh who you talked with in Rhode
Island
um uh on the cape do you think we're
going to see resistance on crabgrass by
using the same product I think we have
identified some dinitroanolin resistance
on crabgrass uh what do you say
yeah I think it's definitely possible
um something you'd want to be careful of
it doesn't seem like the crabgrass is
quite as has quite as a propensity to
develop resistance but I I definitely
you know it's not a bad idea to rotate
you know pre-emergence herbicides and
that sort of thing I think the trick is
how do you really rotate though when
thiopure prodiamine and pendama have the
same mode of action so
um you know using post-emergence
products if you see stuff slip through
is one way to manage for resistance
um it doesn't again we've I've heard of
instances of it but it doesn't seem as
widespread as it is with goose grass so
all right listen we're past we're past
the time but I got uh one more question
because I'm probably not going to get
you again for a while
um just like I think we're equally
concerned about Goose grass nut said
she's getting to be a bigger and bigger
pain in the ass and all we've got are
these sulfony ureas in New York we don't
have dismissed yeah um I know we've
always said you got to make these
applications around the summer solstice
right it seems to be where you can get
some post and some pre-activity I know
we've said to them put in crop oils or
methylated seed oils
um is there any insight into nutsedge
management that you can get done in a
year or two or are we basically looking
at large infestations taking a a couple
of years to to get under control
nutsedge yeah it's always going to be a
multi-year issue because of the tubers
but one of the things we've looked at is
earlier applications actually timed at
pre-crab grass so mid April and we've
done it with Kalinga 2 and that's been
funded by PBI because they've got the
new vexus product out and then they're
going to have the liquid archon so those
those were you know what's the active in
those products it's pyramid sulfan and
you have it in New York oh we do um so
it's an ALS inhibitor it's yeah yeah
it's so familiaria but it's pretty close
I mean it's the same mode of action yeah
um and and I think because they've got
the new product coming out they've been
looking at different ways to use it so
we've actually found that mid April
applications followed by another
application six weeks later actually
works really well and I think the key
with nutsedge is maybe not waiting and
trying to get it as early as we can and
realizing that these products actually
have a little bit of soil residual as
the shoots kind of emerge through they
apparently at least the vexus is hanging
out in there long enough that uh we're
getting good control from that strategy
and I think you know the the nuts Edge
begins to produce new tubers just four
to six weeks after the shoots come out
of the ground so
um even waiting till the solstice might
be too long depending on the area I mean
I think still think that's a good time
but
um but yeah we've had luck with that
early work the key is though you got to
know where it was the previous year
because you're you know if you're in
mid-april you don't have nothing hard to
see or you got a scout yeah so I think
the the thing that I've taken from all
this is there's no such thing as too
early with nutsedge I think again we're
still it's still kind of early we
haven't published any of it and it's but
we've got a couple years of data on both
Kalinga and crabgrass with the vexus and
the archon
um and I think Halo sulfuron might do
the same thing but we haven't looked at
it so we need to take a look at that
more but that's that's my two cents on
on nutsedge but I I think realizing that
you've got it's going to be a multi-year
battle no matter what because if you let
it go say like we did last summer when
we had you know a drought it can be one
of the more competitive things in the
landscape when we've got a dry summer in
the turf occurring and bringing soil
moving and soil around listen Matt we
had no problem filling up the fastest 30
minutes it only took us 34 minutes
thanks so much for taking the time best
of luck with the growing season
everybody else thanks for joining me
next time we'll be with you we'll be in
at least three weeks from now when I
return from a short uh vacation with my
family in Europe so until then uh thanks
very much Matt and we'll see you in a
few weeks thanks for having me thank you
this has been a production of Cornell
University on the web at cornell.edu